yes so why you not grateful and remember
who gave you life for
free I am grateful but is it do okay let
me ask you this question if you want to
buy a gift for your mother would you a
gift that you love or your mother love
something that my mom likes like you
want to be grateful to your creator the
way he loves not the way you love he
tells you how he to thank you that's why
that's why you Islam when we say
the first pill of Islam what is it is
that you testify there's no one worthy
of worship except Allah that oh Allah I
want to be grateful to you I want to
appreciate you I want to worship you the
second part testify Muhammad the
messenger of Allah meaning oh Allah I'm
going to worship you according to your
teaching through your Prophet
Muhammad so if I'm a Muslim he's a
Muslim both us if we live at the time of
Jesus the only way to worship God
correctly is by following Jesus that
time likewise if who lived at the time
of Moses is the same thing cuz all of
them came with the same message and they
came at different time now the last
prophet is Muhammad who came to hold
mankind Jesus came only to the
Israelites as we mentioned in the Bible
in the St so even we look to the
prophecies that Prophet Muhammad
mentioned for example you know about
interest interest which like bank and so
on yeah Prophet Muhammad said it will
come a time when interest will become
widespread even if you are not involved
directly will affect you
you know if you have a bank account
now yeah even account contract that's it
so they are utilizing your money for
interest and look at look at the word of
the Prophet Muhammad he said even if you
are not involved directly will affect
you you'll be affected by it and this
happen exactly you know sh I'm trying
every day you know but sometimes I feel
like we have that knife knife you have
to be slowly give him a knife yeah I
know I know I Jing I you know one thing
at a time you know yeah but
but look his intention is good he wants
to know the truth it's just because he
was raised very strict he thinks he
similar he thinks it's like no it's
similar in a way SAR way like we believe
in we believe in Adam and Eve which
Christians believe we we believe in
Jesus he was born as a father however
the Christians they start worshiping
Jesus you know they went a wrong way in
the most fundamental thing which is the
Oneness of God so just I believe in
Trinity that's true that's true
understand but generally speaking
Jehovah's Witness do you know about them
yeah I know about Jehovah Witness Jo
does the same thing they do they still
pray to Jesus even though they don't
believe in Jesus to be God but they
still pray to Jesus oh you know that
they don't believe Jesus yeah I know I
know of course yeah I know about Je
Witnesses about I know about also you
know about what they call it aites eite
is one of the earliest uh uh group in
Christianity naar no no eite was it was
in Palestine eonite and nazarin which we
call nasara so nazarin they were in a
time of the time of Jesus and they were
the first the followers of Jesus who
were called nazarin the term Christians
was invented by Paul Jesus never jesuses
that's it Jesus never called his
followers Christians they were known to
be called nazarin and look how the Quran
go is so right called
him and that's accurate follow of one
God yeah
and why they called Nazar because from
the area called Naz Jes of Nazareth
that's why they're called Nazar yes like
a London is London okay yeah so so we do
believe there's a lot of sim
similarities however the Christians
divide diverted or deviated from the
most important aspect of religion of the
prophets and G of Moses and Prophet
mammad which is the Oneness of Allah
like I said of course you're going to
take a big step Jehovah's Witness is
same same they still to to they say we
don't believe in Jesus to be God but
they still pray to Jesus so when you
pray toay to Jesus yeah they pray to
Jesus this the only thing why I love he
said to me Z Zak you know I'm looking at
Jehovah's Witness it makes a bit of
sense yeah said why yeah you know I mean
like even I don't know much in it I
don't know much but you know you know
about the Bible uh uh you know even I
don't the Bible firstly Jesus what
language he
spoke Aramaic AR no no Aramaic Aramaic
or syri okay they differ historians
differ either syri or Aramaic this uh
language is very ancient language we
don't have nothing directly from Jesus
in is a pure
language we in Greek so it's been
translated by translated we don't know
them if we don't know them can we can we
trust them you can't trust them that's
why when you have the Bible I have two
Bibles here I have King James and I have
ESV and Jehovah Witnesses they do follow
ESV and nav so when you look at ESV
there's many uh uh differences for
example if you go tobl please to if you
go to Matthew 17:21 King James is there
and ESV is not
there yeah look if you go to Matthew get
the I'll show you if you go to Matthew
17:21 watch yeah yeah one second let me
just get something to show you I want to
demonstrate this what King James yeah
Matthew 17:21
yeah okay this
17 okay this 21
yeah okay come come come to the light
here
look however this kind does not go uh
out except by prayer and fasting 21 yeah
I've read that before I read that before
watch this give me the other one this
Matthew 17:21 this ESV this is Jehovah's
Witness this the one they use yeah je
does they like to use this one je uses J
Witnesses uses New Living Translation
yeah that's the one translation yeah
this same this one new translation they
they still use this one as well Matthew
17:21
yeah
okay 17 he this 22
Yeah
19 20 where is 21 no way wait no
way no
even if you go to the footnote this is
the English Standard yeah yeah yeah ESV
if you go look look if you go to the
footnote they will tell you cuz look if
you know there's number five here yeah
no way look here they say number five
way yeah yeah
okay Matthew
1721 yeah is here is here look here 21
however this kind of
prayer yeah that's crazy yeah KJV that's
my Korean one that I use English
Standard Version go
English there we go English Standard
Version Matthew
1721 there the 21 it's not
there that's crazy yeah it's not there
I'll give you another one come I'll give
you another one you know you know the
story be here all day bro you know know
the story
look how many notes he has this some
research also you know the story about
Jesus about the woman Christian yeah
okay but what I'm showing you that
because he said you interested about
jeah Witnesses even jeah Witnesses you
can't let's say they don't believe is
wrong it can't be right that's it yeah
that's it and you know what prophet
Muhammad mentioned that or Allah
mentioned in the
Quran that the the Christians have
corrupted their scripture and we can
demonstrate that right now there's many
p in the New Testament which is not in
the I mean in King James which is not in
the
nav and they tell you why because the
early King James was made first didn't
it Wasing yeah but but this one is based
upon earlier manuscripts what NIV NIV
and ESV yeah and it tells you why they
it's not there because earlier
manuscripts did not have it so it was
added later on by scribes so you can see
people yeah people start you can see
people start bring interpolation
s yeah of course big F you know I watch
so many of your
videos make picture for me quickly bro
he's looking into this I know I know I
know I know make I'll
take we'll just do a normal one it's
good I know I'm Co I'm going to be like
yeah yeah I need a chair
try the flash as well flash yeah I can
do it for
you come I'll give you a book
[Music]
come who's the back H I show you more
okay before I show you more here look
this for you okay let me show you more
how come okay watch
this okay so we have here mark this is
King James version yeah King James let's
go to Mark
11:26
see imagine that they say we love the m
Mark 11:26
yeah
1126 yeah but if you if you don't not
forgive hold this 11:26
yeah if you do not forgive your father
and yeah father neither will your father
in Heaven forgive you yeah yeah yeah
I've read that before 11 26 here now
let's go to to ESV there's
25 okay 27 sh there's no
26 25 what the heck no
26 that's the English Standard Version
yeah this ESV and they checked even from
your own
one you know there's many many I can
show you so how can you chust this this
book
it's not it's not just humans because
the Quran was passed down to us by
humans but the Quran was the Quran is
preserved of course what the what the
miracle of the Quran Allah said in the
Quran we have made Quran easy to be
memorized now if you go to Asia Africa
Europe America you will find Muslims at
the age of 10 and N M the Quan word for
word letter for letterer even though
they don't speak the Arabic language
yeah they don't speak it's like imagine
let me give you an
example imagine all of us here we don't
speak French and we memorize this book
in French language and you know what we
pronounce it so perfectly that is a
miracle how we even speak French how was
in the book difficult to pronounce yes
so so so the Quran is not like the Bible
the Bible is based upon a manuscript
that you discover in the cave in uh in
Palestine or Egypt you know what I'm
saying or Iraq but the Quran was Quan is
a living thing meaning when I say living
thing meaning was passed down to us
always we recite it in a mosque we
recite it can I ask yeah go ahead ask
okay let's say I become Muslim can I
live my life however I want to live it
that's contradiction huh that's
contradiction it's a contradiction you
know why it's contradiction like I will
go to heaven if I believe in
um and I say the thing what was it was
it yeah what's that again if I say the
sh you become Muslim alhamdulillah I
believe that Allah is
only true God yeah then I'm done I can
live my life however I want no but this
is not you see there difference between
Islam and Christianity Christianity is
about Bel Islam is not just believe
believe and action of the limbs if you
love your mother so much would you not
show her through your
actions would you not sure you will show
her yeah I think is like this though it
I I understand where it's coming from
when you become Muslim first you know
when you accept Islam we don't expect
you to change everything I always give
this example in IM you have a big cake
front of you listen carefully you have a
big cake if you eat all of it at once
what would happen to you sick your but
in order for you in order for you to
feel the sweetness of the cake what you
do you take it bit by bit likewise Islam
step by step the first thing is the
shahada when you take shahada then step
by step because it's illogical for you
to change everything yes all of us me I
was born a Muslim you know I I I had
crazy lifestyle I went prison I was
involved in robbery I you know czy
lifestyle it took me time to stop
certain things which Islam holds is
Haram but alhamdulillah the most
important thing which you you saying is
a sh because if you say SH now and you
live may Allah forbid if you do die
straight away to
Paradise I said it before you said no
but I said as a belie but you said it or
said it for the sake of argument because
if you say as a belief conviction
brother you
know say as
I said
it no that's what I'm saying that's why
I'm showing you what Islam is a truth
for you to be say you know what it makes
sense so I accept Islam you understand
because Islam Islam means to submit
yourself to your creator and look you
know let us utilize our intellect yeah
our logic Islam said do not drink is
alcohol good for us or bad for us
alcohol is bad for us it's not bad yeah
it's not good for us it's not good for
us okay not good for okay fornication is
bad for us for going around sleeping
with we don't want to do for your sister
or your daughter likewise care about
people's families yeah likewise interest
when Allah said don't not do interest
interest is bad for us is slavery
interest is oppression okay when Allah
said to when Allah told us to not do
something evil not because he hates us
because he loves good for us understand
it's for good intentions for your own
benefits you for your own good you
understand for example when Allah said
to pray prayer is for you you know
there's too many depression too many
stress too many troubles too many
problems prayer is when you say allahar
what does it mean Allah is greater than
anything else so regardless how much
problem you have when you are praying to
Allah Allah is greater than your
problems you see when you bound down
you're showing humbleness humility to
your to your creator you Pate likewise
Islam charity so whatever Allah told us
to do is good for us individually and
collectively whatever Allah taugh us to
stay away from is better for us
individually and collectively because
you know Allah is the L of everything so
when Allah told you to pray or to give
charity to be good to your father and
your mother and to worship to worship
him alone this this something which is
good for you you understand so like I
said to you my wife became Muslim when
she was 14 bro alhamdulillah now she's
proper Muslim Mah she also no no my wife
she's a Caribbean solution yeah yeah
yeah alhamdulillah yeah yeah so
alhamdulillah so I'm saying
bro which is remember when I said if I
saved your life what would you say say
you would thank me and you would
remember me all the time but you don't
know who I am I could be a murderer but
because I sa something is so dear to you
you would thank me what what about
thanking Allah the creator of everything
the one who gave you everything while we
speaking we are benefiting from Allah's
blessings which is oxygen breathing yeah
yeah you know what may Allah forbid if
something bad happened to you and you go
to hospital and they have to give you
oxygen they will charge you you're going
to pay you're going to pay you get it
for free that's what Allah said if you
try to count Allah blessings you will
never be able to do so and remember bro
this life is temporary don't this life
is temporary don't let this life deceive
you yeah p is
Everlasting so don't choose this life
which is full of depression and stress
over Paradise which is full of enjoyment
and everything you desire and
everlasting you see but the key to
Paradise is sh then of course prayer
giving charity and step byep
but always I the people how many people
left the houses they never come back how
many people W sleep they never wake up
you know promise for tomorrow you know
what I'm saying bro may Allah forbid if
you cross the road something can happen
to you and and disb believe in Allah is
the most evil crime against God turn
away from God you understand bro so if
you make sense it's clear to you now
when you say sh you're going to say it
based upon conviction you think you know
what it makes sense I want to then step
by step start learn how to pray give
charity you know Prophet Muhammad told
us visit the graveyard why the graveyard
summarized this life for us that all of
us we going to end up there and when you
die God doesn't care who you from or is
your skin color it's about your belief
and your actions if is your belief is
sound and you have a good actions before
that Allah's Mercy you understand but I
know as a young man there's a lot of
Temptations out there you know you want
to do this you want to do that but the
most important thing what's your name
got your name k huh k k k okay K yeah so
the most important aspect is sh and
Prophet Muhammad told us when someone
accept Islam all his sins forgiven
except if you have a debt or you took
something from someone unjustly you have
to give it back to him or to her but
whatever between Allah is Forgiven it's
like newborn so don't let this stop you
you know remember Satan will try do
everything to stop you from accepting
Islam I like that you studi the Bible
alhamd study other books as well you
understand cuz you know when I want to
speak to people I'm not going to speak
to them based upon lies and you know I'm
going to tell them if they're christs
I'm going to quot their own books you
understand so alhamd if it makes sense
to clear to you should become
Muslim alhamdulillah don't let nothing
stop you bro you know let me ask you be
honest with yourself
bro be honest with yourself may Allah
forbid imagine you die today and I'm not
scared of death I'm scared of like the
physical like you know what I'm saying
that's what I'm saying but I'm not
scared of like my spiritual like no no
you don't know you don't know brother
look look you know brother that people
you know now you can say whatever you
like because death has not come to you
once someone ask me sh if someone put G
gun in your head yeah that be scary that
that scary but say I'm not scared but no
one put G in my head that's why I can't
say it I don't know what will happen to
me because you know you cannot trust
your heart your heart does not belong to
you you know how many people talk in a
war I'm going to do this in a war way
yeah yeah yeah I know I know understand
cuz in a time of hardship and there you
don't know what happened to you remember
Satan can play with your heart so my
point here is imagine you you meet Allah
the almighty the creator of everything
and you and you never accept Islam what
would be your valid excuse or reason for
not accepting Islam Today I went to the
mosque the other day what would be a
reason a reason if if you meet Allah
today and you die today and you meet
Allah say why why were you not Muslim
what you
say it didn't make sense
oh he has no reason if it didn't make
sense then it's good I don't think I
feel guilty though like there's no like
heavy pressure you know what I'm saying
I wouldn't feel guilty you feel guilty
on that day yeah I feel guilty